I'm mostly holding cash and waiting for
winter to come and I'm going to buy
businesses personally as well
I just yeah I just want I want
businesses you don't own any like uh
Vanguard index fund [__] you just are
literally sitting on I imagine tens of
millions of dollars of treasury bills
yeah
[Music]
all right on today's episode we got
Andrew Wilkinson joining if you don't
know you gotta know Andrew is the
creator of tiny tiny owns like 20 30
businesses at this point they own
dribble they own Aeropress basically he
buys and sells buys and sells businesses
of total value maybe over a billion
dollars at this point
um definitely over 100 million in
revenue and
um and he's sort of known as the the
Warren Buffett of the internet or that's
the model that he chose to create so he
didn't do the startup path he creates
one genius idea he didn't do the
investor path where he's just putting
Small Checks Into these companies
instead he was finding these little gems
of businesses buying them and he's been
doing this for like you know I don't
know 10 15 years now and uh Andrew's
become a good friend he's a friend of
the Pod he listens to the Pod so he
knows the vibe he's probably the most
well-liked guest that we have so we're
always happy to have back in this
episode we talk about
preparing for winter so how what moves
he's making or has made in order to
prepare for like you know what's going
on in the economy so what he's doing in
his business what he's investing in that
sort of thing we talked about a couple
of his new ideas or businesses that he
started one uh like negotiating as a
service or procurement as I'm told or um
or this other company called
um actually I don't want to give it all
away but he talks about a couple of the
ideas that he's working on and then we
go on some tangents about why you should
only rent your house and not buy houses
we talked about
um
you know uh different ways that he gets
together with other entrepreneurs and
groups it's a good episode so about an
hour and a half I think you'll like it
uh all right enjoy this episode
dude wait hold on Sean I haven't seen
you in a minute where are you what you
you good oh dude I've been literally
sitting at Tesla charging stations for
like the last year of my life it feels
like I made a horrific mistake of
renting a Tesla for a road trip where'd
you go just from here to LA from the
from the bay to LA and I thought okay
that's cool might have to stop once or
twice it'll stop five times basically
every 90 minutes I had to stop for 30
minutes it was awful how fast were you
going were you going above 80 no nothing
not fast two kids in the back and a
bunch of you know snacks like it was
this was not like some
this is not me it was you that's how I
felt that's how I felt towards the car I
was like apparently this isn't what most
Teslas would be like but the Tesla I had
rented you know was uh was not the
greatest and which kind of sucked
because this was my sell my wife on a
Tesla's the next car trip and uh I had
the opposite effect you know what's
interesting is like I bought a Tesla
like maybe eight or nine years ago and
it was insane it felt like you know
going to the future or whatever and I
just bought the new BMW IX which is like
their electric SUV and you realize that
the main feature of the Tesla is how
quiet and fast it accelerates and
instead of being a Tesla feature you
realize oh that's just an electric car
feature and then as soon as I get in my
BMW I plug in car play so it's like the
Apple interface and you realize like at
the end of the day these electric cars
like there's really not any competitive
Advantage
um you know and Tesla frankly the
interior is so much worse than BMW and
all these German and American
Manufacturing lectures so like I'm
really curious to see how it all plays
out now yeah they've done such a good
job of rebranding uh fake leather to
vegan interior and uh that's what they
say they say it's vegan friendly
interior I'm like oh you're just low
quality like the fake leather and
whenever I sit in them they feel like
plastic I'm not a Tesla fan I also think
that they're like super not sexy
yeah like the model X looks like a weird
big toe or something I mean I think like
it's they're great they're great cars
like I I really like them but I just
think that everyone overestimated their
competitive advantage and that at the
end of the day you've got all these
Legacy manufacturers and you know
ultimately if Apple and Google are
providing the interface that most people
use it barely matters right it's just
like a platform with an electric motor
that takes you from A to B and then you
know does it work with your iPhone or
your Android uh and if you look at the
Tesla interface it's like really bad it
you can't sync your Maps up on the
screen or anything like that it's it's
not great
so Sean you're not getting one
uh actually I still probably will get
one but
um
yeah I gotta like do research and [__]
now like I joined the subreddit for
Tesla fans it's so crazy by the way how
many products are just for Tesla owners
because you basically have I don't know
how many million but like like in the
subreddit alone there's two million
members and that's and that's Reddit
reddit's like the niche part of it right
so like I don't know exactly how many
cars Tesla has sold now but
um somebody can grab that I think
they're doing they did like a million
this quarter delivered or something like
that something crazy like a huge huge
jump but let's say that there's five
million Teslas out there those are five
million High net worth people who can be
targeted with specific products and I've
seen some people do this uh one guy had
this thing called Tesla I forgot what
it's called like Tesla uh camper or some
[__] like that it basically would turn
the trunk of your Tesla if you fold down
the back seat and you open up the trunk
of it it would turn it into like a
sleeper van and um it was just like a
bed that goes in the back of a Tesla
it's perfectly made to fit in the back
of a Tesla it looks sleek like a Tesla
thing and it was like
there and they were doing like you know
they're doing pretty well these guys
would do seven figures on just just this
one product with very minimal ad spend
because they can go highly targeted with
content Instagram and stuff like that to
to reach Tesla owners and then same
thing people selling these adapters that
let you charge everywhere or there's an
app because I was like trying to plan
the road trip and I just typed in the
destination and like you know it gives
you a suggestion on where to stop to
charge but it wasn't great that's why I
stopped five times I was like there had
to be a better more optimal route uh
than this and there's some old ass app
called a better route planner or
something like that abrp and it's like
the number one ranked thing the
interface looks like it's you know from
the 90s and um it just does a slightly
better job at like giving you some
custom control over what what charging
stations you should hit on a trip
and I just realized like wow there's
this is like a um it's like Rolex owners
or things like that like these high net
worth
um communities that are super passionate
and they're locked into that ecosystem
uh you know Apple being the biggest
example of this like the big like the
Apple blogs that's that were out early
on right huge over time uh this is like
there's the same opportunity with Tesla
and other products like that
that's awesome yeah maybe maybe I'll be
getting one too but we'll see
um so so we should reintroduce Andrew so
Andrew Wilkins is back uh definitely the
the the number one
guest of the Pod both in our hearts and
the fans Hearts so uh and I don't know
why we don't schedule more of these
because like we should but uh every
quarter or so Andrew just texts us he's
like hey
I want to come on I got stuff and we're
like great pick a pick a day let's do
this and so he's back he's the uh
founder CEO of uh of tiny and they buy
beautiful internet businesses he's done
a bunch of pods with us in the past
explaining that stuff but he's also he
also listen do you still listen to the
Pod regularly I know you used to listen
to the sauna at night yeah all the time
I take little breaks because I get too
pumped up sometimes when I listen like
in the song really yeah listen I
listened in the shower of the sauna
usually
[Laughter]
all right if that lasts for more than
four hours I'm always fully I'm always
fully nude when I listen to you guys
would it make you feel comfortable now
if we turn the cameras off and take off
our clothes
that would be ideal so you had a bunch
of ideas or topics Sam you want to go to
yeah so you got you have a bunch of good
[__] uh where do you so we're going to
talk about like what you're doing for
winter meaning like what you're doing
with your personal and business finances
given that the economy may not be going
well uh we're gonna talk about like
different ideas that you have
um I want to talk about the anonymized
workers so you like you've been hiring
some Anonymous folks and then you also
have uh like five or six companies that
you've started and we're gonna do like a
postmortem on them and like say like
what went well and what didn't go well
so Sean you're starting yeah all right
great I was gonna say you you drive Sean
because Andrew already told me a lot of
his stuff so I want you to tell me
what's most interesting yeah let's start
with winter so Andrew baby Tee It Off
which is uh I think there is a consensus
now that like we're either in a
recession or going to be in a recession
and that this is not gonna end uh soon
give me your take on what your what you
what your view is of the market and then
what are you doing to prepare for that
situation yeah so I mean there's this
great quote by Andy Grove only the
paranoids survive so ultimately like
none of us know what's going to happen
right like we could have a rebound I was
super terrified like when kovid hit I
thought the world was going to fall
apart and it didn't but what I do when
something like this happens is I stress
test my business so if you think about
it like um if you're about to drive your
family in a minivan across a large
Bridge that's like you know a kilometer
in the sky and there's a one in 20
chance that bridge can't take the weight
of your car you don't want to drive
across right doesn't matter if you're
probably going to be fine you just don't
want to go across and so I think you
want to stress test and over engineer
your business for all the worst case
scenarios no so effectively you know
that's what I've been thinking about a
lot and I think what people Miss is
there's two ways that you know something
like this can go bad right the worst way
it can go bad is total loss right you go
bankrupt your business fails you're
embarrassed it's terrible well I think
that's the worst but the less bad option
that no one really talks about is
missing opportunity so you get presented
with something incredible and you're
illiquid you can't take advantage of it
so for example let's say you're an
e-commerce company and suddenly ad rates
drop you know 5x and you could go out
and take the market and sell shitloads
of your product uh you can't do that
because you're you're a liquid or you're
just barely holding on you don't have
any cash reserves maybe there's an
amazing acquisition
you can merge or take over a competitor
or something but you can't do that so
you get instead of Errors of omission
you get errors of commission you're not
able to actually execute on those
opportunities
um and so you know I've been thinking a
lot about this over the last couple
months and generally we operate quite
conservatively uh our goal is like you
know any debt we have we want to be able
to pay it off pretty much at any time we
try and keep as much cash as we can at
head office but there's a couple
specific things that we're doing that I
figured I'd share that could be useful
so number one is what is a stress test
so that sounds cool I want to stress
test my businesses great I sit down
today what the heck am I doing to do
that okay so you would say
um okay what happens if Revenue drops 50
in this business right are you able to
lay people off is that a possibility are
you stuck in a bunch of long-term
contracts and leases that you can't get
out of do you have a lot of debt that
you can't pay
um you know you're really modeling out
like what I'll do is just do a simple
spreadsheet and say like okay if Revenue
goes up by 20 here's what it looks like
if it goes down by 20 if it goes down by
50 if it goes down by 70 percent or for
example one thing that often happens is
you still have customers but in many
businesses they have accounts receivable
and people stop paying so people they're
gonna pay you but they might just pay
you late maybe in 90 days or 120 days
and so what happens if no one pays you
for two or three months do you have
enough money in the in the bank do you
have credit lines Etc so
um I think you know it's really wise to
kind of do that Shadow Boxing and
imagine a bunch of nightmare scenarios
us so that you can sleep at night
great yeah
actually continue where you're going
continue where we're going then I'm
going to ask you a question
yeah okay so I'll talk a little bit
about like what we're specifically doing
um so
everyone always says you know the best
companies get started by during a
recession which is absolutely true
um but at the end of the day I am not
going to be putting a lot of money into
crazy Venture bets and what I mean by
that is I'm not going to be taking like
a lot of risk right so I'm not going to
go and invest in the e-commerce company
with 500k of Revenue at a 12 million
dollar valuation I'll still keep betting
on new companies
but I'm doing it in a much more
conservative way so for example we have
an Angelus rolling fund we invest about
12 million dollars a year there and I'm
pivoting it to totally focus on
secondary and minority buyouts so for
example a Founder who gets cold feet or
wants to buy out their business partner
something like that I'll do non-binary
deals so what I mean by that is like if
revenue and earnings get to where they
say they're going to be the valuation is
one thing if they don't the valuation is
another so kind of our investors win in
either scenario and then the other one
is Strat uh like structured deals so for
example saying to someone look I'll give
you a five million dollar valuation but
I want a guaranteed 15 return in the
case of liquidation or dividends and
that kind of stuff and then also
I mean you guys have talked about this a
lot but the idea of default alive I want
to be investing in businesses where if
they can't raise the next round they're
not going out of business
um and then the the other thing with
Venture is like we've realized too
we can do Venture internally by
incubating businesses with low downsides
so for example like turning our p l
expenses into businesses in and of
themselves so for example like we want
better procurement internally we want to
negotiate rates and get our p l under
control and so we started a business to
do that we want to you know get better
credit across all of our businesses we
started another business to do that so
that's the kind of stuff we're doing
with venture
we just we just talked all about that
the other day
and what was your take Sam
uh um what on what he just said I think
it's I'm I should do that I am doing
that or I'm doing something different
uh
part of me thinks that like that's a
little well I personally wouldn't do
that because I'm like man when [__] gets
bad I get afraid and I just want to
focus focus focus and when I think of
like you starting something new I'm like
whoa aren't you gonna have to like
allocate like another 500 000 to this
salary for buyer.co and like uh or you
know like however many of the salaries
and however much it's gonna cost to do a
new website and so I get I get nervous
about that so are you not are you baking
those into like new expenses are you
saying like look I could just go and cut
costs and save a little bit of money or
I could go spend a little bit more money
build a company around it
well I'm looking at businesses like
there's been businesses where okay
here's an example so when we started
buyer which is our negotiation service
for software that we launched two years
ago and we ended up selling it to ramp
so I think we started that business for
50k at the end of the day we're looking
at it and going this is a very low risk
bet where we're basically finding
someone who you know they want to start
a company we're giving them all the
tools to do it and we're going to
partner with them provide all the
capital but at the end of the day we're
looking at really really simple Capital
light businesses that can get Revenue
within like two or three months I don't
want something I mean I've done I can
talk about this later but I've done
businesses where we go for 10 years that
are never profitable and we're just
pouring good money after bad I you know
I don't do that anymore what are you
doing with your personal uh portfolio at
the moment what's that like what's those
percentages look like where where each
thing is so
um basically it's cash so I have
treasury bills and then I also have a
the only stock I hold right now is
Pershing Square Holdings and the reason
I really like that is a it's trading for
far less than the value of the
underlying assets so it's a holding
company that owns a bunch of Blue Chip
stocks and it's trading at about 66
percent of the net asset value so if
there's a hundred dollars of stocks
you're paying 66 cents and then they
also are
most of these kind of like uh holding
company types trade at a discount
anyways
not to this degree right at the end of
the day like this is why isn't for the
type of fund it is uh well I think
there's a variety of different reasons I
mean it's illiquid it's traded in Europe
uh it's run by Bill Ackman who has had
you know a few blow-ups and people
associate him with blow-ups if you
actually look at his record he's killed
it
um and the other thing I like about that
business by the way is that they own a
very large position in interest rate
swaptions so as interest rates go up the
fund actually does better so over the
last if you look at the net asset value
over the last four weeks it's barely
moved while the larger market has gone
down significantly but anyway I'm mostly
holding cash and waiting for winter to
come and I'm going to buy businesses
personally as well
I just yeah I just want I want
businesses you don't own any like uh
Vanguard index fund [__] you just are
literally sitting on I imagine tens of
millions of dollars of
treasury bills yeah
and that's why what do you do I guess
where's your main focus with your
balance sheet like uh how much of your
worth is in your personal accounts
versus let's say If you think about okay
my my net worth how much of it is
associated inside tiny and you need to
be smart about what you're doing inside
tiny versus Under personal because I
think for most entrepreneurs most of
their net worth is in their in their
business and then their personal kind of
checking accounts savings accounts and
stock trading accounts are much smaller
in comparison
yeah I'm like 90 in Tiny But what I have
done is I've had I've had liquidity and
other things outside of tiny
um you know tiny is a holding company
that I co-own with Chris and there's
been other assets like Legacy assets
that have sold
or cash flowed and so I've taken that
money and compounded it and done stuff
with it personally and the way I look at
the personal money is if everything goes
pear-shaped with tiny I still want to
make sure that I you know can retire and
be free and have enough money to do
stuff so it's a little bit more
conventional but you know what's funny
is you know you're like oh you don't
have ETFs and stuff as far as I'm
concerned I do have an ETF because
Pershing Square Holdings owns 10
positions right so it's a diversified
stock portfolio and it just happens to
be managed by Bill what percentage of
your net worth or sorry if you have one
number in treasury bills how's that
compared to the other number in
purchasing squares Pershing Square
um I think it's 50 50 right now and one
thing that I've been following is
basically like uh two years ago so or a
year ago you own or Co you're a major or
I actually don't know what your
percentage is I think uh it's in the the
annual report but uh you own Wii
Commerce which is yeah a collection of
Shopify plugins as well as a few other
products that's like a really really
good business I forget what it said in
the annual report but it's publicly
traded it's like 50 or 60 million dollar
a year in annual revenue and it's Peak
stock was like 600 million dollars it
was crushing it now like the rest of
tech it's just been decimated to like I
I what is it today I I think it's like
80 million or something so how does it
feel like you're the only person I know
who's like this wealthy well I know we
talked to darmesh our master's like yeah
I lost like 200 300 million dollars the
other day uh how's like what's it feel
like what's it where's your perspective
and where's your emotions when you're
seeing this thing
destroy it and be amazing at 600 million
all the way down to 80. like how do you
feel about that so I think if I was just
like a pure one of the interesting
phenomenons I've seen is people who are
great entrepreneurs often are just great
entrepreneurs they don't become
investors they you know they don't like
thinking about the stock market and
finance and stuff I actually really
enjoy that side and so I've spent the
last 10 years learning about investing
and reading about Warren Buffett and
Warren Buffett's Mentor Benjamin Graham
has this whole idea of Mr market right
so the stock market is like this Moody
person it goes up and down at the end of
the day if you know what your business
is worth it's irrelevant what the stock
market says it's worth so personally
I mean yeah like sure there's a little
bit of an ego hit seeing your net worth
have some zeros pulled off of it but at
the end of the day I know that number is
made up anyway so for me it really
doesn't affect me day to day I just go
do I still own a great business well in
it you're you're personally you're fine
like you've got liquidity and you've
helped all these other things going on
but like
um I imagine let me put let me put it
this way there's a great Buffett story
and he says you know Sam let's say you
own a farm and it makes you a million
dollars a year of profit right and some
Yokel walks up and goes hey Sam I'll
give you fifty thousand dollars for that
farm you just go go away like no I'm not
gonna sell and then someone else one day
comes along and says hey I'll give you
20 million dollars maybe you consider
that but the idea is that at the end of
the day these yokels will yell numbers
at you and you don't have to sell right
unless you sell that's when it matters
right if you sold for 50 Grand because
you're panicked because you're going oh
the economy's in a recession maybe my
farm will crumble and you sell for 50
Grand yeah that sucks but if you ignore
the yokels it's irrelevant and in the
same vein we all own houses and the
houses the values fluctuate constantly
but we don't feel that right because you
don't see a ticker or if you own the
hustle there was times where if the
hustle had been publicly traded it would
have been worth next to nothing and then
there are other times where it would be
worth crazy numbers right and and you at
the end of the day you know your
business you know what it's worth
yeah Dharma said this thing he goes
valuation oscillates around value and I
just had this image so you know so
imagine you're creating value in this
business the line is going up and it's
pretty steady it's really it's quite
hard actually to have like dramatic
jumps in the value of your business or
dramatic downs and then dramatic highs
again it's like that's not really how
values created in most businesses and um
and he's like but then value is this
like crazy Moody line that's swinging up
and down on like higher and lower than
the value at any given time and if you
have to be able to differentiate between
the value of a business and the
valuation of a business and that's I
think what you're what you're talking
about totally
you want to talk about some of these uh
what do you want to go to now Sean well
I was gonna say uh I have the opposite
strategy as Andrew as I often tend to do
with most of my friends I have the the
opposite strategy Not By Design
I wish that was not true but uh like for
example right now I'm doing more I'm
putting more attention and energy and
doing more deals in Venture than I did
in the past year the past two years
really because with your personal money
uh well no the fun money but I'm you
know I'm the steward of that Capital
right so and it's and the the returns of
that my I have personal money in there
as well but like the returns of that I
think are going to be pretty meaningful
personally but um this amazing thing has
happened which is that all the founders
have just read bad news for like six
months straight and this has done two
things one a bunch of like
nuts a bunch of people who would have
quit later quit now which is fantastic
because picking is really hard in
startups and so like you know thanks for
making it easy we're like you meet a
Founder who's just sort of like yeah so
what like okay okay who you know who
cares about what's going on in the world
I'm still gonna do this thing I was
obsessed with it before just because
there's a war in Ukraine and a pandemic
and the stock market's down and crypto
is down doesn't change my interest in
this like Niche thing so you see that
person you're like okay great they're
they're in it for the long haul you see
other people who are pivoting like crazy
and you're like okay they're not really
in it for the Long Haul the second thing
is that they've cut all their valuations
by like 40 to 60 percent or more the
same deal yeah or more uh so the same
deal you could get you know for 10
million you're now getting for four or
five million right 20 million you're now
getting for 10 million and so but but
the reality is that that same business
was gonna exit seven to ten years from
now where like the market like they're
reacting they're changing their
valuation based on today's data but
they're you're gonna get paid out so you
get to buy cheaper but you get to sell
seven to ten years from now when the
market conditions are going to be
dramatically different than today and
likely a lot better than whatever this
next you know kind of down cycle of the
market looks like over this year next
year whatever however long my Worry My
worry is Anchor bias right so I mean it
if you think about it everyone was
saying Venture evaluations were crazy in
2019 right let's say the average seed
and you know or or sorry Angel uh
valuation was say 5 million in 2019
which was much higher than it was in
2016. in 2016 I would see deals for one
to 3 million so then it goes to 5 and
then in 2020 2021 let's say it goes to
20 million right and then it comes back
down to five and we all go oh wow it's a
crazy deal right so My worry is that
these businesses should actually be
valued at one to three million because
if anyone came to me with most of these
businesses uh you know as a as a cash
flow real world investor it just looks
insane yeah but you send me a way to get
your money back is to have a massive
exit right
for Venture right a venture deal will
look horrible to any private Equity type
of buyer and in the same way a private
Equity deal to a venture capitalist will
look also horrible because their their
criteria and their lens and their model
they're based on fundament like totally
different factors and Andrew on this
yeah
you said I didn't invest in slack when I
had the opportunity I didn't invest in
this or that or this and you've made I
don't know dozens or maybe even hundreds
of Investments so you you walk the walk
as well but you you said I wish I could
have done this I wish I would have done
that I made a huge mistake to do that an
exercise that I do all the time that I
try to do all the time is I try to ask
myself what like you know like we
constantly say like oh I wish I would
have known that this company was going
to be as big as it was and I wish I
would have pounced it on that and I had
that opportunity or there was this
opportunity that I had and I missed it
and I always ask myself what is
happening this second this week this
month where I'm gonna look back and
there's a chance that it's gonna say I
really just screwed that up like that
was a like for example for me it was
when I was running the hustle Facebook
ads I could buy users for a dollar and
they were worth ten dollars to me so
like I knew at the present this is a
good deal and I didn't go harder on that
and I'm missed that opportunity and so
right now I'm wondering you know I about
eight months ago Sean and I were like
dude we're never gonna make money on
Angel Investing because like the
valuations are 20 million dollars when a
company should be five million dollars
and like these whole this whole like
idea of like a Tim Ferriss investing
fifteen thousand dollars into Uber and
making 50 million dollars that can never
happen with us the numbers just don't
work now I'm seeing these numbers and
I'm like
is that happening right now is this
opportunity does this exist the second
I would say you guys have a very unique
opportunity because of your profile now
right I think like Tim Ferriss was able
to get into the best deals because
people wanted him in them and you guys
are going to have that same opportunity
but I guess the question is
foreign
are you playing
um are you playing roulette are you
playing poker I play poker right I want
to play with very good odds in my favor
and I want to know the odds I don't want
to play roulette where it's almost
totally random I still think Venture is
totally random I do it for fun off the
side of my desk and don't get me wrong
when I see I look back and go I could
have predicted maybe not slack but
certainly there's some of the businesses
where I could see it was quite obvious
that they were going to be winners and I
could have pushed harder to invest in
them
but I still look at that as kind of
random because I've had that feeling on
businesses where I've lost everything so
for me what I'm saying is you're about
to enter an environment where anyone
with cash who has a large sum of cash is
going to be able to buy a business at
say a 20 or a 30 earnings yield meaning
you can buy a business and pay yourself
back in two or three years maybe five
years and you can buy good businesses
right because everyone's gonna be
panicking and wanting to sell there's
going to be great opportunities to me
I'd just rather play that poker game
than Venture right now and I'm focused
on it it's not to say I'm not going to
do Venture Long Term and if a friend of
mine who's amazing
comes to me and says hey I need a
hundred thousand dollars for my company
I will invest all day still I'm just
saying I'm not focusing any energy there
right now what's an example of a company
that you tried to buy recently and they
wouldn't sell or an example of a company
that you can you can reveal now and it's
no big deal because it just it won't
happen but is there any companies that
you that that are good examples of this
uh well there's one really weird one um
bridgebase.com I started playing bridge
like five years ago and it's kind of
like chess.com there's all these nerds
that play the website isn't particularly
good but I was quite impressed by you
know all the numbers behind it I think
it ended up selling to someone else we
looked at chess.com uh that ended up
obviously blowing up with everything
that happened with Queen's Gambit
um I mean there's all sorts of
businesses I I won't kiss and tell
um because you know we still might look
at some of them
um but we've looked at a lot of kind of
off the beaten path interesting
businesses like that where you find like
a nerdy cohort of people that have a
dedicated place where they all gather
how much you think bridgebase.com sold
for I'm looking at now it looks like it
has like I don't know eight million
monthly unique visitors it's it's pretty
huge yeah I think my mom uses this
um by the way that little kiss and tell
line I have this sheet on my phone where
I just save a little throwaway lines
that like I call them get out of jail
free phrases or it's basically like how
do you use a phrase
in certain specific situations I'll give
you another example so Andrew just did
one where it's like you get kind of put
on the spot and you don't really want to
share so you have a phrase that gets you
out of it smoothly safely securely and
like no damage done versus
um you know what there were many other
things that he could have said in
response that just would have been like
sort of awkward and another one my uh my
uncle uh told me this once he goes
he was like trying to do this deal and
it wasn't really working and I kind of
we all kind of felt like I feel like
this deal is doable but we're just not
there yet and like maybe we just need to
like you know if you just wind a dime
this guy a little bit like I think it
would happen but you can't just tell
somebody I'd like to you know want to
die in you that doesn't really work and
he's just like you know my mentor told
me you got to meet someone belly to
belly if you're really ever gonna do a
deal with them and like whether it
happens or not you never regret meeting
another man belly to belly the guy
laughs he said okay yeah sure and and he
used that as the to get what he wanted
which is I'd like to meet you in person
in a kind of informal way and I have no
agenda like I can't come up with a new
agenda to do it I'm just telling you
that this is something I believe
fundamentally that that two people need
to be belly belly if they wanted if they
ever want to do it you have an entire
folder dedicated to these phrases what
other folders do you have and what other
words are in that folder like you use
one all the time like don't don't piss
on my leg and tell me it's raining um
yeah like it's like how do I how do I
get my point across you know with a
little bit of humor a little bit of
geometric and a little bit of like
uh ambiguity versus just speaking so
[__] like because I have this problem
I'm really direct so I kind of needed
these tools in order to do stuff and I
stole this actually from Neville Neville
in his copywriting course when I was
creating my copywriting course I had
taken other people's to see what do they
know that I don't know what are some
useful things they've taught and one of
the things he teaches in there is he
goes um what is he called like he's like
transition well he has this long list of
like transition phrases and it's like or
like it calls it like slippery
transitions or something like that and
basically it's like
we all know that you should kind of
start with small talk and then get to
the beat if you just go straight to the
meat it's a little bit like aggressive
and up front uh but also it's hard to be
like you know Small Talk Small Talk
small talk
so anywho
um do you want to do that you know like
would you like to buy my product and
it's like oh damn like you know awkward
and so he uh he has a long list of like
his little connector phrases and I was
like oh that's really useful actually
like this is a useful thing to get out
of a course so when I created my course
I started creating like these Banks of
like phrases headline formulas
transition words like different things
and I'm like this is your go-to when you
need to sign off or something like say
hello in a fun way sign off in a fun way
give a you know transition or like you
know give somebody something that's
direct you know and I saw I started
creating those for myself dude belly to
belly is a good one yeah it's a good one
right like face to face doesn't have the
same touch
gets a chuckle and you're like okay I
understand what you're trying to do
Andrea are you doing any writing at the
moment you're all you've always been a
great writer but you have it doesn't
seem like you're really producing a lot
are you writing for your companies or
anything
yeah I'm working on a book actually what
really on what yeah yeah just about
um the story of building our business
and just yeah like the experience that
I've had over the last 15 years What's
it gonna be called
I don't know yet I'm still figuring it
out I just signed like a book agent and
uh I think I I think I sold it but yeah
we'll see it's fun I mean it's funny it
goes back to like um I think I've spent
so many years frantically writing like
Twitter threads that disappeared to The
Ether and I love I love the idea of
actually building a narrative story and
writing something more substantial and
I'm really enjoying that process
um and it's just it's a new thing right
it's a totally new thing to learn I'll
share some stuff with you let me tell
you a little book story that will give
you so somebody when you tweeted out
you're coming on you're like oh what
should we talk about there's a bunch of
questions a bunch of good ones honestly
but uh one that stood out to me was this
guy goes give us can you guys each tell
us like an example of a butterfly effect
moment in your life meaning a chance
encounter you had with somebody uh or
somebody or something that like just
like nudge you in a different trajectory
that kind of changed your thing and at
the time it didn't seem like this
Monumental decision or event it just
seemed like this kind of harmless chance
encounter and um and your book thing
reminded me of my answer to that which
is that
Once Upon I think I've told the story
before Once Upon a Time my dad uh was
supposed to come to this meeting and
he's like he's supposed to go to this
meeting in San Diego he's like oh you
should come with me I was a college kid
at the time I think a junior or senior
in college and um he said come with me
and I was like okay I guess like I'll
just tag along I'll shatter you for this
I've never done that before so it's kind
of a random thing that my dad tried to
do and then my dad's flight gets
canceled my dad's coming from Indonesia
at the time so his flight gets canceled
and I'm like oh shoot I'm already at my
connecting stop like I'm like wherever
Kansas City and like should I what
should I do he's like oh just go do the
meeting I'm like I don't even know the
context like I don't even know what you
do for a living how am I gonna talk to
this guy he's like don't worry this
guy's great um and I told him you'll be
there and he he just said come hang out
with me so I go to San Diego I meet this
guy and the guy comes in as like a ball
of energy and he's got Neil Centuria he
comes in as this ball of energy Charisma
he's immediately cracking jokes he's
telling me a story he walks in and he's
late like 25 minutes late I'm just
sitting in this room and he goes he goes
ah man I'm sorry I just got off the
phone with Kyle whoever Comcast he's
like let me tell you one thing you got a
pen get out your pen write this down and
I'm like I I just met this guy he
haven't even said hello yet he doesn't
know my name and I like go get my pen
because like I'm the little [__] that I
am and he's like um
he's like write this down if you have
great customer service you can run the
world you hear me run the world and I
was like and so he's like this character
and it turns out this guy at this crazy
career where he he built like skyscraper
in San Diego because he's like oh real
estate's where I'm gonna make my money
then he's like you got into Hollywood he
wrote two like you know like scripts for
films or something like that he was a
showrunner for for a bit and so he
thought that's how we would make it then
he started tech companies with the
internet boom and then he married the
woman who started 100 flowers and he's
like just had this crazy career he
invested he bumped into a guy in an
elevator invested his company and it
ended up becoming like Chegg or
something like that like it's a big
multi-billion dollar thing so he had
this crazy like he's just wowing me with
all this like this like afternoon
basically he takes me to this restaurant
to go eat they have a special table for
him and the tablecloth is all made out
of paper it's a high-end restaurant but
his was made out of paper like a kid's
table and they had crayons that he would
just draw diagrams and like cut deals at
this table and he didn't he never had to
order they would just bring out loads of
food and then he'd walk away at the end
like an Uber he'd never had to pay and I
was like I don't know who this guy is
but like that's what I want to be in
life I I want to be this ball of energy
who's just cutting deals drawn on tables
and like you know has had five different
arcs of his career in these different
spaces and he's still like I don't know
this guy's like 65 70 years old he still
seems to have all the energy in the
world so and then I just like went back
to school and like but if I hadn't had
that I don't think I would have had this
blueprint that like being a entrepreneur
could be cool and it could have like
more variety and I didn't have to like
choose one thing I like I just saw this
one example for one day and it was like
a dream basically then it was done I
never talked to this guy now he's still
there he's still in San Diego and he's
like guest teaches at some school there
and he's got this mega mansion on the
top of the hill and uh that's what he
does that's awesome that was a good
story but oh sorry the book part on the
way out he's like um so I'm with this
guy for two and a half hours and then
I'm just like whoa I don't know what the
hell I just saw I'm 21 years old I've
never I've never like in college don't
meet people like this I didn't at least
so this is the first time I ever met
somebody like Dynamic like this and
somebody who had made their own path and
didn't just like follow their major into
some career and um on the way out he
just shoves a book in my hand and it's
his book and uh it's called I'm there
for your baby and if you want to read
this guy's book it never sold a lot of
copies I don't think but he wrote he
wrote a note to me in it handed me this
book look and then on my plane right out
of there I sure enough read the book
cover to cover and by the I like the guy
by the time I was done with the book I
loved the guy and so I always I remember
that because I was like oh I've always
thought of books in one way as this like
I don't know Mass Market you're trying
to become a best seller or something
like that and then I realized a book is
just a tool that like anybody can use
like some people use their book to get
public speaking gigs but this guy used
it for a different thing which was he
could turn a like it into a love it uh
just by handing this book it's like cool
I met you for two hours or an hour I'm
not gonna talk to you anymore but this
book will sell you on me and like what
I'm all about through entertaining
stories and whatever and um and I was
just remember thinking oh that's a great
idea to do so that every person you meet
for the rest of your life you can
convert them into being a a Believer and
a buyer and a fan of what you do and
that's actually how I want to use my
book when I write a book
foreign I can't find this client info
have you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a
CRM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
serve dueling databases HubSpot grow
better
I did this um like personal values
exercise like six months ago or so and
when I thought about what do I actually
want what do I actually like why do I do
business it's I want to meet interesting
people and one of the great things about
being on Twitter or coming on this
podcast is that I'll randomly bump into
people in a coffee shop so I'll be
sitting there and some guy I'll walk up
and say hey I heard you on my first
million I want to tell you about my
business and I ended up making all these
new friends so I've probably made like
20 new friends from this podcast I've
had random lunches with people uh
literally like I've been in line for
lunch and someone's been like hey want
to have lunch and I have and so the next
level of that is yeah like a book you
get to exist when you're in line for
lunch like if you can't say no well yeah
sure totally but it was great the guy
with the guy was super interesting he
had like an airplane leasing business it
was it was crazy but um but I think a
book you get to exist in someone's brain
for like 20 25 hours sense exactly that
right you can actually get someone to
truly understand who you are and then
when you meet them you don't have to do
your Preamble you don't have to do your
pitch you don't have to do what that guy
did with you you don't have to sell you
can just be yourself and they already
know the deal and I think there's
something really cool about that so
speaking of meeting interesting people
let me ask you guys if you would do this
so I was talking to Nathan Berry the
other day Nathan Berry you know he owns
convertkit or he owns the most all of it
he's probably worth two or three hundred
million dollars he's worth a lot and he
told me how when he travels sometimes
he'll organize like he'll stay like if
he wants to go somewhere for seven days
he'll play in an eighth day that's
dedicated to work and what he'll do is
he'll do like a six hour meeting where
he'll let like 20 or 30 people all come
and hang out with him but he charges
them and it's almost like a very
miniature conference and I could maybe
I'm butchering a little bit about what
he does but basically he's like I got
the inspiration because base camp Jason
fried and those guys used to do these
things where they would charge 200 to
two thousand dollars and
um you can come hang out at their office
and I thought uh you know I should do
this when I travel and it will pay for
my trip and also I can meet interesting
people and I thought about this and the
cons are it could feel like Sleazy and
weird to like well I'm charging money
for my time but I think he actually said
Andrew he went to one of your things and
you gave the money away I think uh like
you yeah and I was like yeah that is the
sleazy part but
it is kind of a cool way to like meet
people that cross a certain threshold
and it could if it could like pay for
your trip and even though it's like well
I don't I don't I have enough money that
I could pay for my trip there's
something about it that I find so
intoxicating to do this have you ever
thought about it
would you do this Sean and Andrew yeah
what are we gonna say
I was going to say I really struggle
with this so like you guys are I think
one of you guys is on intro I'm on intro
because listen I'm friends with the
founder this
I don't even have any I don't even think
I have well I don't have that many dates
available but my friend started it and
he's like hey use this I was like fine I
started using it then he puts my ad
everywhere on on Facebook and so I only
make like an hour or two available a
month and it's just crazy it's just a
service that lets you meet Sam Parr
that's I'm pretty sure that's what intro
is based on the ads that I've seen
that's oh my God they are killing me
with all these ads well it's a terrible
way to use your time right like what we
did we did a um a charity ask me
anything so we're like okay anyone who
pays whatever you donate will double it
and um I think we like suggested the
donation or whatever but with Nathan and
about 20 other entrepreneurs we did like
a zoom spent two or three hours
answering all their questions I think we
raised like 50 grand for a charity which
was pretty cool
um but I really struggle with this kind
of stuff because at the end of the day
you're selling your hours and I don't
want to be in that business
um but it's fun it's a fun way to do it
and but I feel like it compromises the
it like people expect value right so if
you're on day eight of your trip and
you're exhausted you now have to dial it
up like that guy that met you in San
Diego you have to be like histrionic you
have to wear a mask you have to like
pump yourself up and I find that one of
the things I've realized is I'm very
capable of doing that like I can I can
be miserable and I can pump myself up
like Tony Robbins style like jump on the
trampoline and all that crap but it
makes me miserable and so I just don't
want to do that would you do it Sean I
would not charge
um for that mostly because if I'm doing
that it's because I want to meet
interesting people so I'd rather say
filtered or I have the right to just
stop talking to your boot you out and
like the next fight like I can make
these meetings 10 minutes right so Brad
fell did this in bradfield's a VC in
Boulder he's probably like one of the
main most well-known Venture capitalists
in Boulder Colorado and he used to have
this one day on his calendar every month
called the random random day or
something like that he would just let
you book a 15 or 20 minute meeting with
him he'd just sit in a coffee shop and
he'd sit there for four or five hours
and he'd just try to meet as many people
as he could and he had no filter there
he's like you don't need a warm intro
you don't need this you don't need that
and first that was great branding for
him of like I'm a man of the people uh
you know it's like when garyvee does
these tick tocks and it's like
it's just some you know somebody who
comes up to them and they look like you
know they're like Haggard and they're
they're like Gary can I just get a
minute of your time he's like of course
I'm anything for my my fans and he's
like he said Gary you know how do I um
I don't have enough money for dinner
he's like here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna take that guy's dinner and
sell it now you got two dinners give him
back one and you got one for yourself
it's like he gives them this like pump
up thing and the guy's like thank you so
much and they hug and they Embrace and
I'm like wow I don't want to touch
anyone who listens to the podcast you
know it was like I just here's a rule
we're not touching like touching is not
happening
you know like that's just not a thing
but he does it gives a a brand Vibe of
like Gary's one of the people he's a man
a man of the fans and so um similarly
Brad would do this and I thought there
was immense brand value for him doing
this and then the second thing was I'm
sure there is some when I met him I was
like why do you do these uh because I
went to one and he goes
um he goes you know you have to create a
landing spot for luck and other people
call this a surface area for Serendipity
but like you want to give in your
schedule someplace first of all those
are both both of those phrases Sean gold
a landing area for luck and surface area
for Serendipity sorry go ahead those are
both beautiful yeah future book titles
uh so so basically you wanna you wanna
create like intentionally create space
because the more successful you get the
busier you typically will get by default
and the less space goes on your calendar
Buffett and others like you know Andrew
you do this too where you just carve out
space I'm gonna think I'm gonna read I'm
gonna walk I don't need to have meetings
after meetings after meetings because
guess what if I let that happen that's
exactly what's going to happen to my
calendar and what this guy did I thought
was interesting was cool if I just stay
in my bubble and I only admit people who
on the surface like are you know worthy
of my time or whatever then I'm just
gonna miss out on a whole bunch of other
things and so how do I carve out you
know what's the one percent of my time
or two percent of my time that I'm
willing to allocate towards Randomness
luck Serendipity just so I can like have
that in my in my mix
it's amazing how that goes away like I
remember when people would email me
early in my career I would be so
flattered like they'd write me like four
paragraphs I'd write them a really
thoughtful response and get on the phone
with them and then you know you just get
more and more of those and you waste
your time like they're only interesting
maybe like one out of five times the
rest of the time you want to offer
yourself and so I basically stopped and
then it was like oh [__] how do I get
that Serendipity and to be honest going
on here is a great form of serendipity
because of those random uh meetings and
introductions and stuff but most the
time if someone emails me I honestly I
delete it unless it's like one line and
super clear if it's a pitch or anything
I just delete it I I found my my most
navalism Naval thing that I can't my
original Duval quote where I realized
like the point of this podcast is not to
be well known I'm putting point of
creating content is not to be well known
meaning known by like a lot of people
but rather to be known well so like
what's happening now is in my inbox or
my DMs people are sending me stuff that
is so interesting to me or they're
making intros that are so on point and
the reason they can do that is because
if they listen to the podcast they know
exactly the type of [__] I'm into and
that Sam's into and so we get this like
amazing inflow of just dope stuff that
we didn't have the eyes and ears out
there to go see and
um that's when you know it's working
like for anyone out there who wants to
create content don't make your goal well
known make it known well and you'll know
it's working because you'll start
getting more than your your you're being
asked for in these emails or DMS and
Andrew I'm sure you you get the same
which is like people send you either
interesting companies or deals or they
want to come you know work for you and
they want to help you solve specific
problems because they know you well they
know what you're what you're interested
in what you're what you're looking for
more of dude I had a guy just recently
send me so he goes hey my website does
this much revenue and this much profit
and he told me all about it and I didn't
reply and he goes what you don't believe
me and he sent me a Google drive with
his tax returns like had his
that is
social and everything and it was 100 his
tax return I mean I guess it could have
been photoshopped but and he goes and
then his reply was like see told you I
didn't say anything small boy stuff that
is absolutely stuff the tax returns it
was like 17 million dollars of income
and and he sent me multiple years uh and
it was hilarious it was one of the best
things and I was like you know instead
of like uh Casey neistat and Dave
Portnoy used to do these awesome videos
where they would unbox all the fan mail
that they got and it was actually really
fun content I'm like we need to have
like an unboxing our inbox
you unbox your tax returns people just
send us their tax returns and we didn't
open it up and we react we created a
YouTube React channel just to your
income and your business to your piano
is that guy want to does does he want to
sell or get you to invest or what was it
supposed to be friends he was just
wanted to be friends
you know Joe Rogan Rogan has this like
famous YouTube clip where he reads some
quote from some guy which is like most
someone famous but it's like most men
lead lives of you know quiet despair or
something like that and he's like so
true you know most people walking around
that just have this this the sadness in
them and there's a version of that for
rich people which is if you are rich but
unacknowledged
there's something in you that just kills
you and I mean we get this a lot for for
the podcast so much where people are
just like hey I just need to like it's
like you go park at a mall or whatever
you're like can you validate my parking
that's how I feel it's like can you
validate my my wealth can you validate
my career it's like yep here let me give
you the punch hole like this is amazing
you're you are way wealthier than me
you're way more successful than me
you're probably smarter than me but they
haven't they don't have the platform or
the audience where they get that sort of
congratulatory thing like maybe the
people in their life they can't brag to
they can't tell their employees how well
they're doing you know there's no need
to go do a press tour about it so it's
like that would be uncomfortable but so
then they just sort of like damn nobody
nobody I won the game and nobody knows
dude we've had so many people Sean who
we've mentioned and they've reached out
to me and I noticed that that just that
mention it's they now view themselves as
like a public figure they start creating
content and things like that and I want
to tell them like hey just so you know
you've already won and it's like
everybody's asking me about my skincare
routine and it's like oh yeah it's like
you know they get that little taste of
that that Fame that hit those likes and
they're like I guess I should abandon
this working formula that's generating
mounds of wealth in order to write some
threads baby what's that what's that
quote it's like would you rather be the
world's greatest lover and have nobody
know or be the world's worst lover but
have everyone think you're the world's
greatest lover right there's so many of
these uh world's greatest lovers walking
around dude speaking of being a lover
Andrew you have like a little bit of a
five o'clock shadow right now and your
jaw is looking chiseled you look this is
the best I've ever seen what's going on
have you been getting some work done
what's going on here yeah extensive
facial reconstruction no I've just been
powerlifting for the last six or eight
months it's working awesome
they're coming through the Riverside to
Sam right now anyone who power lifts is
just like automatically turned Sam on
yeah
I'm not the Sam par shirtless photos on
Instagram level but I'm getting there
okay so that's another example that's if
you get there let's say let's say when
you get there and you're just you're so
proud of yourself but now nobody knows
everyone still thinks you're just a
normal looking dude but now you know the
truth are you gonna get your parking
validated are you gonna post something
but maybe like you know uh you gotta
like you know do the fake uh fake like
humble thing where it's like you know I
gotta be honest I'm so proud of myself I
was really depressed about my body and
nobody talks about this so that's why
I'm coming forward with these selfies
just I needed to be vulnerable here guys
check this out
who's the um who's the guy he was on
Silicon Valley the Indian guy and he got
jacked what's the mail on Johnny a
comedian yeah like like think about that
experience for him right because he had
the biggest version of that uh yeah I
don't I've done that I've I personally
have like progress photos and stuff and
I showed my friends but I would never I
don't think I would ever post I've seen
them online I can't do it I think they
look great I've seen them are you sure
less ripped than uh chamoth who's you're
he's an investor in your thing right do
you guys exchange you know I definitely
am less definitely less ripped than
Jamal no no no no no no no no I don't
think so you guys you guys are you guys
are right around the same area he's just
dark so so you know darker always looks
more uh cut you know what I'm saying
yeah my problem is I've got a hardcore
Farmer's hand so my arms get dark and
then my entire body is basically
translucent you can see my heart beating
through my chest so it's not the best
for a six-pack
that's amazing yeah you're like what
white privilege have you ever seen a
man's heartbeat
so um all right let's do some more I
wanted to say one thing real quick you
had said something that I thought was I
want to say this because
um this is one of the most interesting
observations I had about my own like
investing misses that I like made a firm
note to change
um so you talked about creating
businesses off your off your p l so you
look at your expenses and you say oh we
spend money you know on SAS fees what if
we could create a business is it by the
way is the new one called buyer or is it
called something else now
no we actually started one gun deal
maker and because buyer did software we
sold it to ramp they're doing that we
have to do something different right so
basically the story there was we Chris
and I were maniacal about negotiation in
the early days right when you're the
owner of a business say you saved 30
bucks that's 30 bucks in your pocket
directly and what we noticed was as we
as we got bigger and bigger and bigger
we had managers and CEOs running the
businesses their comp based on hitting a
very large number and so if you know 30
grand or 30 bucks doesn't really matter
anymore but to us the owners that really
matters and so we were like okay how can
we make this easy for the CEO because
nobody likes the discomfort of
negotiation I hate it and so the idea
it's it's very uncomfortable I I don't
like it either right I know all the
tricks I've done it now I just don't
enjoy doing it but if I can Outsource it
to some Scrappy person who loves to
negotiate a car or a house or a lease or
whatever it is I'll do that all day long
and so we created this business called
dealmaker dealmaker dot Co and instead
of doing software we're doing like
office leases Furniture Insurance like
all the random stuff in your p l and
basically just CC them and they take a
cut of whatever the savings are
um and I just this is something I wanted
myself because I was going oh my God
like I had the experience of
um you know when you're when you're rich
or people know you're rich they will rip
you off if they can right so a recent
example is I got Wi-Fi installed in my
house and they had to wire the house and
do some stuff it was tens of thousands
of dollars and I was like holy [__] it's
too late now I could have just had like
an arrow installed in a mesh Network or
whatever but instead I did like the You
Know Rich fancy thing and got it all
custom wired right or another one is in
our office we got drapes and we got a
quote and it was twenty thousand dollars
for some white drapes I looked at Ikea
we could buy them for like two thousand
dollars right so I've just realizing
that we have a Target on our back I
think anyone who runs a business does
especially when times are good and so I
think having someone to negotiate on
your behalf is a very good idea how did
you how much did you fund this business
with it it looks cool the site looks
good
yeah I think it may be like 50k like
like I said we don't put large sums of
money into this stuff we basically find
really Scrappy operators where we can
basically say look we've got all the
back office all the structuring legal
it's ready to go we'll build the website
for you you just need to take it and run
with it and we go typically like 50 50
or 70 30 depending on the amount of
capital we have is it working yeah so
far I mean I think it's profitable you
said it's pretty you said you didn't
need much to be you just CC deal maker
so you're like when you're talking to
your vendors or whatever you just CCD
maker deal maker in and it's like
basically like hey you know here's my
brother who's gonna beat you up
it's like think of it as like
procurement Department right so like if
you go to Walmart like we used to work
with Walmart uh at metalab and it would
be like okay here here's what we want
we'd say like this is the number and
then they send you to procurement and
procurement is a guy who's literally a
professional negotiator who crushes you
and they Crush you in so many different
ways right it's like your hourly rate is
too high your payment terms you know you
said 15 days we want 45. and so it's
just about getting the most in my head
I'm just imagining like a bunch of like
young guys like like shaking in their
boots like oh we gotta meet Mr picker
and he's like this scary guy and you
walk in it's just this like dork with
like a horrible like half beard with
like mustard on his white shirt that
short sleeve it buttoned up like looking
like Dwight and and it's just like the
nerdiest guy ever and he just like
starts rubbing his nipples like thinking
about a good deal like oh yeah
there's a great there's a great book
called I will teach you to be rich by
ramit Safi and I read it like 15 years
ago and he makes a really good point he
goes look you're not you don't get rich
by paying attention to like lattes and
like building budgets and like not
buying lunch out you get rich by paying
attention to these macro big things in
your life so for example when you buy a
house there's a massive difference
between getting a three percent interest
rate and a two percent interest rate but
no one thinks like that and so this is
the stuff you want to Outsource to
someone else and have them do it you
know you buy your car you buy your house
you get it off how does this business
buy twenty thousand dollars of furniture
how are you actually pulling this off
like how how what's the what's the
what's the work behind the scenes to to
to do this deal
it's literally an army of guys who love
to negotiate and we train them up we you
know we give them all the books that we
read and we have a process and you know
they get cc'd and they go for it and
they basically say look you know your
first quote was X we saved you why give
us the cut of the savings and and go for
it in some instances they'll retain us
so like for example let's say there's a
company and they're like we want to do a
super thorough review of everything then
you know they might pay a retainer or
something but usually it's just being
cc'd my dad should work for you my dad
is incredible at this he will like but
he's very unorthodox you can't train
those well it takes time here's the
thing is like you and I like if we were
I remember I walked into a car
dealership and I go to the guy and I say
I have two hours and if you can get me
the car in two hours I will just sign
whatever you want but I need it in two
hours right that's the worst possible
negotiating thing but I value my time
and I don't want to sign documents I
have a friend who will literally go to
five of the same dealerships gets quote
from all them name drop them to one
another walk out five times do like 10
test drives show the guy how rich he is
in a variety of ways to know so he knows
he's serious and then finally his he'll
save you know ten thousand dollars right
I'm just too lazy but there's other
people that where it's totally worth it
and the numbers are here picks up the
phone oh yeah Derek I'll be there
shortly I'm just finishing up here I
don't think I'm getting what I want here
so I might go over there oh you have it
ready for it well that's great I'm just
gonna hang out here for 10 more minutes
in case something changes
my dude my dad will be on the phone with
some company like but he does it for
petty [__] like he'll just try to get
like you know
you know like you know when you it's
like dad you can't negotiate with the
grocery store yeah no no literally he'll
he'll call like the airline and just be
like you know why is it why did you
charge me for my seat they're like
that's how planes work and he's like and
then he'll be like you know I've been a
customer for a long time and
Palazzo just most people will just bail
because it's too awkward he'll just sit
in that [__] he'll just be like and then
they'll be like oh that's you know we've
loved having you sir and he'll be like
long time
just very nasty behavior and he's like
he's like whoa nasty Behavior what are
you talking about like nothing is
happening we just did the normal thing
here we just charged you for the product
and he's like
yeah this is It's just upsetting
okay well sir we gotta go now
we need like a I want a text folder of
all these phrases
Trump will be like you know people are
saying people are saying it's great
they said it's great you know
people are saying that they're saying
that and he's just like keeps going with
this statement that's my dad dude
instead of so often so often it's just
silence just being silent saying like
you said throwing out one of those
open-ended statements and then just
staying silent and holding the
discomfort and then often they will
start to you know give on the price or
whatever and you just realize like most
people will just avoid social
awkwardness dude you need instead of
deal maker you need to have like comp
maker or salary maker so many people
myself include news for salary when I
was negotiating my salary for HubSpot
when we sold the company they I remember
my wife was in the room but she was like
on the other side of the computer screen
so they couldn't see and they're like
telling me a number and they told me a
number and I was like yeah whatever you
know whatever whatever's cool
my wife was on the other end like what
the [__] shut up
it's all good
I remember
that's actually a really good business
idea maybe we should is that like a
coach where it's like a coach so it like
you know you don't because it'd be weird
if it was like a third hey I'm doing a
comp review this is Jerry from my
procurement team Well here here's how
you could but if you had that guy
telling you like do this do this do this
dude listen here's why it could be cool
is because I remember I got a speeding
ticket recently during the pandemic in
like rural Kansas when I was driving
across country and they were doing Zoom
things so like Zoom I and I was like oh
I'll fight the ticket because I actually
think it's nonsense and so I had a
lawyer I don't know if I'm breaking any
laws here but I had a friend lawyer and
I would be like hey I'm gonna put you on
speakerphone so you could hear what
they're saying and then just text me
what you think I should say in court so
I could fight this ticket and try to get
off of it and she was on the phone like
listening like all right ask them this
and I asked them this so they'd ask them
this and the lawyer or the the judge was
like wow you really know what you're
talking about I was like oh yeah you
know like I just I really didn't think I
did anything wrong and you really just
need that for like when someone's just
CC all emails part of the salary
negotiation negotiation or have them
there like
listening to the zoom and like all right
now say this now say this and then just
give me half of the earnings that you
you just got gone up by when I was at
twitch they were like
um yeah the salary uh is this and I was
like
oh um
I just let him sit in that and I was
like and they're like you know
they're like uh sorry did you say
something and I was like oh no just
lower than I thought
um and it was just like I don't know
buying time and they're like well you
know I was like can you explain how the
process works I just so instead of like
saying I want more here's a different
number I was like can you explain how
you guys get to a number like this where
does this number come from
and like you know where do babies come
from they're like they don't know and
then they're like and then they said the
magic word they're like there's a we
have these bands which is like a band is
like code for like a range which is code
for like we're trying to see how much of
a sucker you really are like basically I
was like oh so you're telling me for my
role uh there is a specific minimum and
a maximum band of compensation that I
could get and you're offering me
anything but the absolute top of the
band or pay better yet have you ever
gone out of band and gone higher what
situations would cause that to occur
they're like well somebody needs to
vouch for it like they have to go to bat
they have to write a memo I'm like cool
all right now I know what I'm gonna go
ask for and I basically just like work
through the system but once you realize
that these are all a negotiable and B
like there's actually it's like playing
a a like a a robot you know like that
can only make certain moves on the board
and you're like oh you can only go
forward and backwards oh great so I'm
just gonna go around you over here
because you're bound by these rules of
like this is how the process has to work
and and um and so you know most
companies you can get a lot more than
you're currently getting what have you
guys ever like thought about this when
like you know my wife works at a big
company she's been offered jobs at other
big ten thousand twenty thousand person
companies a hundred thousand person
companies and I'm like Sarah what would
happen if you just told the interviewer
like hey look like uh let's let's screw
this place a little like just tell me
the most amount that you can give me
yeah like no I mean not really excuse me
but like what like what's stopping
they're like look I don't give a [__]
it's not my money I'll yeah let's just
like let's let's let's let's Rob this
place if we can so let's just like I'm
just gonna tell you
across the table Yeah write down a
number here
why is this like 100
000th person employee who has the power
to allocate certain dollars like they
don't care you know it's not the
company's money and I just has always
shocked me that the culture is such that
like they are actually being honest in
many cases to the employer when they
could be like
look I like you
you like me here's the rules I need you
to tell me this and I can then give you
this you know what I mean like what they
don't have enough I can't believe
they're not your friend they don't care
their incentive is to just do the
basement I don't cover their ass like I
guess people in big companies
um let's do uh let's do can we do one
other topic yeah and you're picking the
one that you had prepped that you're
like
you'd feel like ah man we need to get to
that so pick that one and let's do that
okay well let me do one that's
applicable we were talking about winter
coming and I had a story I wanted to
tell so one of the other things
um you know obviously were like you know
stress testing all the businesses we're
dialing in our P L's we're pulling
excess cash into head office we're you
know loading the elephant gun so to say
we want to get ready for a big
acquisition and winter and two two like
kind of interesting things we're doing
one you know this is very obvious if you
have debt you know lock in right even at
a higher rate I think a lot of people
are doing this thing where they're going
well it was you know interest rates were
at three percent I could have locked in
then now they're at you know five
percent I don't want to lock in and
they're kind of anchored to that three
percent thing to me it's about certainty
I want to know that when I build a model
when I stress test the business that I
know that my interest is going to be at
five percent or whatever even if you
know they go up or down or whatever I
just want that certainty the other kind
of weird thing we're doing
we've done this once before is we're
buying um we're buying options on the
stock market so this is and this is kind
of speculative but I look at it as an
insurance policy so
here's an example of what we did in 2020
so
um we started freaking out about covet
we're a little bit early on it Chris and
I locked down kind of like late January
or early February and if you remember
everyone was kind of saying like oh this
might be a bit of a nothing Burger up
until
March 1st or second or third kind of in
that zone and so what we ended up doing
is we're looking we're doing these
stress tests and we're looking across
all of our businesses and at the time a
lot of our Revenue came from our agency
businesses and we had these large
Fortune 500 customers but we're going
okay what's the first thing all the
fortune 500s do they pay everyone late
and so we're looking at okay we're going
to get some late payments that's going
to cause cash flow issues we might also
have some of our startup clients go out
of business and they may just not pay us
and so we started looking at what is the
number there
that we want to ensure and it was like
five or ten million bucks where we were
like okay these are all companies that
may just not pay us we might you know
lose that revenue and if that's the case
we're going to have a bad year we're not
going to have liquidity and so what we
did is we basically said okay in late
February we said okay if this if the S P
500 the index of the 500 largest
companies in America goes down by 20 we
will get a big payout and so we bought
for five hundred thousand dollars put
options that were went out about a year
so if any time in the next year uh the
market dropped that much we would get a
large payout and the idea is it's kind
of like buying an insurance policy on
your house right you pay this premium
you put the money out and you hope that
you just pay that premium and nothing
bad happens but if your house burns down
they'll give you five million dollars to
rebuild it and so what ended up
happening is we bought these put options
they went from being worth five hundred
thousand dollars to seven million
dollars all of a sudden and Chris and I
are like laughing our asses off never
had you know never bought put options
never been through this or whatever so
they go to seven million dollars and
we're like holy [__] this is amazing
let's sell them right and so we sell
them we cash in we take seven million
dollars onto our balance sheet and then
we look at each other and we go well
this could be the worst recession of all
time uh you know are we are we the guys
who just sold our insurance policy like
should we keep holding this you know
what if what if this is 1929 and the
stock market's really going to go down
50 and the whole point of this is to
have this insurance policy and sleep
well at night now we don't have it and
so we take all the money except for 500
Grand we we took 500 grand out we took
all the money and we re-bed it
and we lost everything
came in and the markets rebounded now
there's two ways to look at that story
you know one is we we uh got hit with
gambler's fallacy you know let's go in
we'll do one last uh roll at the
roulette table uh the way that I think
about it is I go I lost my premium right
I I paid for insurance and the bad thing
didn't happen therefore I didn't deserve
to get the seven million dollar payout
and the fact that we sold it is just a
you know that's yeah it sucks that we
had that money in our bank account for
five days or whatever but it really is
irrelevant and so the way to think about
this let's say that you own a SAS
business
and your entire net worth is in the SAS
business and you currently uh you know
you've raised money at 20 times revenue
or something you might want to find a
SAS business that's publicly traded that
is a comp to you and you might want to
buy out of the money put options or buy
a basket of those and basically say if
the market gets crushed that's probably
an indication that the larger economy
got crushed too or my part of the world
got crushed and businesses like mine are
doing badly and so it's kind of an
interesting way to buy an insurance
policy it is certainly a little bit
gambly right but it is an interesting
way to sleep where'd you come up with
the math of like all right 500k well you
can model these out there's a website
called options profit calculator and you
basically say this is the stock and
it'll show you in a variety of scenarios
and so for example in that one I just
said okay in previous recessions you
know a recession is defined as what you
know more than four quarters 15 yeah
draw down over two quarters or whatever
I just said look if that happens over
the next year I will get a payout and I
could look at the different payouts
based on where it went are you buying
any real estate right now
no I hate real estate uh are you Sean
buying real estate no not at the moment
I I hate real estate so much that I
don't build equity in my own houses so I
do interest only mortgages because I
want everything in businesses because
businesses a business can earn a million
dollars of Revenue and then the next
year do a hundred million dollars using
creativity there's no uh apartment
building you can buy that'll do a
million dollars of Revenue and do a
hundred million dollars next year that's
just not how do you qualify for an
interest only loan you just gotta make a
lot of money you I think I think you can
do it via most banks
um generally it might be the sort of
thing where you have to have some sort
of collateral or other assets or be at a
larger scale are you fixed or
effectively
yeah I I'm fixed yes so then you you got
locked in at what what rate like to two
when it was back I think I locked in at
five right I'm one of those people where
I was like you know hey let's lock in at
three didn't do it let it go too long
ended up blocking at 5 live but it goes
back to I want to sleep at night it's
possible interest rates go back down to
two percent and I feel like an idiot but
I want to sleep at night I just want if
if interest rates go to eight percent
ten percent which is you know maybe not
high probability but it's certainly
possible historically I don't want to
deal with that Sean are you buying a
house now no I just rented this place so
it's like a two two year three year
rental
um
yeah I like renting I like renting the
place I live me too I love it for
multiple reasons but like basically uh
buying your buying the house you own is
not a great investment doesn't there's
no yield right you're you are the tenant
um so so it's not like I think people
conflate those two things like if you
buy property that pays you okay that's
an asset if you buy property you live in
and it costs you money that's a
liability in my opinion so so I think
that's the the first piece second piece
is
picking the place you like to live is
not always the best investment like what
are the odds that the best investment of
a pretty significant amount of capital
is the place my wife really likes the
countertops like it's just like it's not
gonna be the place like well that's not
where the value and I'll see you trust
me yeah you have people people that put
like 50 or even 90 of their personal net
worth into a single investment which is
a house and then they go oh it you know
doubled in value over 15 years and
you're going yeah if you just bought an
ETF you would have had the same result
and if you bought an individual stock
you probably could have done way way
better so to me it's like if someone's
completely if they're not an investor at
all then sure go buy a house all day
whatever so say it's a reasonably okay
investment but if you're even remotely
smart and you know how to read and you
go and read investing books and stuff I
think it's crazy I mean I would I would
just rent a house all day and put
everything into equities and businesses
where ending too I I own a house in
Austin
um because uh I I wanted that to be my
residence and whatever we did and I
actually rent that house out now and I'm
not there I would much rather in the
future for like the next 10 years Sarah
and I even when we have kids we're
renting for sure and I want to go a step
further I want to rent all my furniture
too so there's a company called feather
have you guys heard of feather
you can rent furniture on that website
but it's only in certain cities and I
intend to rent a place and I'll and I'll
get a nice place and it'll cost me 10 to
15 grand a month and I'll spend another
two to three thousand dollars a month
and rent all my furniture I want to own
nothing I love it it's so much it feels
so much better not owning uh stuff I was
I'm on my way back now to Austin and I
was in Brooklyn for four months and I
rented a furnished place and it was sick
it made me so much happier I
I'm realizing like so over the last
couple years like I bought like a I have
a house at a lake locally uh I've got a
place in Vancouver I've got a house here
and then the stuff and the management
like just I have to have a staff that
now manage all the houses right and I
own them I you know I do this interest
only thing but I do own them and I am
responsible for them and there's just
constant you know stuff breaking new
furniture hiring designers doing Renos
all this stuff and so you realize pretty
quickly like everyone thinks they want
to have you know 10 palatial Estates all
over the world but no like you're
running it becomes yet another business
to manage yet another p l yet another
group of people who you have to give
opportunity to and have HR around and
everything it's it's uh you know don't
cry any tears for me but yeah it's it's
really annoying yeah I think everybody
uh ends up a prisoner of a prison of
their own making and so you know you
want to design that prison to be what
are you going to be a prisoner to is it
your stuff
is it your properties right like if I
bought a fancy car and I lived in San
Francisco I just be stressed all the
time that it's gonna get scratched or
it's gonna get broken into and like you
know I it would net make me less happy
and less free and so it's like where do
I want to like optimize for is like more
free and more happy and um so you know
cool I need to do some things to make
that happen like maybe exercise is part
of the prison I want to design right
it's like cool I know that if I do this
all the time and I make this a part of
my routine and it's important to me and
I don't miss it and I make time for it
all the time it cost me money and it's
like hard it's hard effort but it has
this payoff of how I get to feel at the
end how much more healthy I can be how
much more mobile I can be et cetera et
cetera and so I think it's not people
think like you got to choose what you
want or you got to choose what you want
to do I think it's also you got to
choose the like you know choose the
constraints you're going to put on your
body and your your time and your
yourself and your psyche because you
will have some and like whether you
chose them or not that's up to to you
totally I mean you look at like any of
these there's all those sayings around
if it floats or flies or other things
you know rent it uh and I think that
should be applied to to most things
frankly and it's just a matter of can
you get the things you want my for the
issue for me is being in Canada in a
small City we don't have furniture
rental there's not a lot of great
high-end rental homes and stuff but I'd
be all over that if I could
well dude thank you uh this is awesome I
I loved seeing you I love uh seeing your
face again it's not like being belly to
belly I'll tell you that it's not like
being belly to belly but dude his face
your face has become a better face in
the last six months your face is yeah
dude you're looking full thick tight
strong thanks guys yeah what's going on
you you guys talked about um I know you
did Camp MFM or whatever are you gonna
do more of that how would you really
regret not going you got the invite you
blew it bro
I know I know I hate basketball no one
played dude it was like like Sean was
the best player there which like we you
know we weren't no no one was that
amazing right now
yeah no Ben on the Pod was like dunking
on people uh Nick Huber was great Sean's
really really good but besides that ever
we were all just like a bunch of more
event it's something I suck at
like you know Sam's Camp MFM is gonna be
like running the 200 meter sprint it's
like oh I just happened to be
amazing at this oh you know guys there's
a track down the street
[Laughter]
oh look a squat rack Andrew what would
be the version of that that you would do
where it's like
it's all right with just the two Staples
are trying to have great interesting
people that are you know curated set of
people coming but the other is we're not
just sitting in a room you know looking
at a whiteboard or a presentation it's
not a conference so it's like doing
something that's a passion that we that
we like and then the networking fills in
the gaps in between that like the ins
and outs the bus ride there the food the
whatever but like the focus is on some
activity what would yours be that you're
like really interested in doing
I don't I honestly I'm not I'm not a big
hobby person I mean like like most
entrepreneurs I get obsessed with
business and stuff and it's been a real
challenge for me to find those things I
just did um like a I do these Forum
groups where I've been in some of these
groups for like 10 years five or six
guys we go into a room once a month talk
about everything that's going on in our
business we do uh I do I used to be an
EO and then I just started doing it
myself and we just did a forum Retreat
and we went to Whistler so you know
beautiful mountain and we all went
hiking we'd go hiking all day go do cold
plunges exercise during the day so
there's activities and there's something
about being in a group specifically with
other dudes where you're sweating and
your heart rate is going and you're
talking about what's going on in life
that feels really good dude
ass whipping
actually yes yes
we went to a spa and someone got ass
whips yeah I bet they did but but we
didn't this thing where we we would like
do dinners and we'd have this pack of
cards and we would just pull random
cards and be really [__] up questions
like what's a what's a rude word your
parents would use to describe you or
like how have you let someone down in
life and I just love that kind of stuff
right so for me it's about how do you
create things that facilitate deep
interest in conversations ideally with
people you have something in common with
so there's a shared Bond but uh I mean
I'd be down old car or whatever your
deck and you're like all right guys I
have a question
should we kiss right now oh my God
the deck said it not me
the deck said it
written and Sharpie
that Retreat
that was too easy sorry I'm working on
my dad humor
all right I gotta go this is great guys
all right guys okay guys
[Music]